inès bensaïd a reçu un avis d'éviction
le mois dernier ses voisins des femmes
monoparentales des réfugiés et des aînés
devront aussi partir le propriétaire
demande de quitter le 1er juillet pour
une période de neuf mois et l'évoquent
des rénovations majeures depuis on vit
dans un dans un calvaire qui finit pas
il ya des gens qui dorment plus la nuit
a déjà qu'ils pensent comment on va
faire ou on doit aller
on a essayé de parler avec nos enfants y
en a qui comprennent pas les histoires
de ce genre se multiplient comme ici
dans l'arrondissement de saint léonard
où les ménages sont vulnérables à lisa
mousty en est un exemple
il craint de perdre son appartement la
plupart des locataires son salaire moyen
je dirais les sens pour ça ce qu'ils
veulent à trouver un logement encore
pour doubler les prix là c'est
incroyable
un propriétaire peut légalement évincer
six locataires s'il veut agrandir
subdiviser ou changer l'affectation de
son logement
selon le tribunal administratif du
logement les locataires doivent être
indemnisées billy cemac durant la vie
utile d'un immeuble des locataires est à
subir les inconvénients de travaux
majeurs
on sait aussi qu'on a des lois des
règlements qui nous impose de faire des
vérifications de faire des améliorations
mais cette association qui représente
les locataires estiment que certains
propriétaires et vinci légalement sous
prétexte de rénovation communisme mais
si c'est souvent des travaux importants
parce qu'il ya un laxisme d'entretien on
va durer ce prétexte pour contrer ce
qu'on appelle les rénovations certains
arrondissements de montréal ont resserré
les critères pour obtenir des permis
c'est un changement qui s'ils pouvaient
être uniforme partout à montréal où
partout au québec
c'est sûr que ça ferait un gros
changement et je crois que c'est la
première chose qu'il faudrait que ce
soit mais on pressent aussi le
gouvernement du québec d'agir
mansfield civile en sicile de ton
direction la ministre de l'habitation
planche plutôt sur une autre solution
renverser le fardeau de la preuve pour
qu'il incombe aux propriétaires de
démontrer le bien fondé des rénovations
au locataire lui qu'est ce qui doit
faire ses yeux le fardeau de prouver
qu'il a été évincé
est ce que c'est vraiment le locataire
qui doit prouver qu'ils ont été évincés
ou encore on pourrait transférer le
fardeau de la preuve au propriétaire
impossible de savoir à quel moment le
changement sera fait d'ici là les
locataires devront continuer de se
défendre
l'une à l'administratif du logement même
si la suite s'annonce difficile
inès bensaïd est décédé à rester chez
elle elle veut contester jusqu'au bout
c'est même pas en discuter
personnellement je veux pas quitter
et c'est le cas de la majorité
il s'y est mais lemieux radio canada
montréal